[Musica]
Ci sono due tipi di persone al mondo gli
esperti e i multipotenziali facciamo un
po' di chiarezza mi immagino il percorso
di vita degli esperti più o meno così
abbastanza lineare perché sono persone
specializzate in un unico ambito come
gli avvocati Gli scienziati gli
idraulici o i parrucchieri
tra i grandi personaggi della storia un
esempio potrebbe essere il renkouri
figlia della più nota Marie Curie
incredibile scienziata lei è un'esperta
perché ha dedicato la sua intera vita
allo studio degli elementi radioattivi
per poi vincere un premio Nobel in
chimica
i secondi i molti potenziali invece sono
persone che nel tempo hanno coltivato
diverse passioni e che sono riusciti a
collegare le tra loro come gli artisti
creativi o gli eclettici
Escher ad esempio artista del Novecento
lui era un multipotenziale perché ha
unito la sua passione per la matematica
con il suo amore per l'arte realizzando
così opere meravigliose che uniscono
questi due mondi
E sebbene l'apparenza gli esperti
multipotenziali sembrano così diversi in
realtà c'è una cosa che hanno in comune
la costanza
nei primi sono proprio gli anni e anni
di studio il continuo e costante
miglioramento nello studio di un unico
determinato tema porta loro ad essere
degli esperti
la costanza nei multipotenziali invece
si esprime in maniera un po' diversa
Infatti nonostante abbiano diverse
passioni loro riescono costantemente a
convogliarle in delle attività che le
esaltano Come è il caso di Escher Beh
ora la domanda sorge spontanea In quale
delle due categorie vi mettereste così
Istintivamente io io
dirvi la verità ci ho pensato a lungo ma
non riesco a sentirmi in nessuna di
queste due categorie così alla fine ho
creato una nuova categoria o meglio una
non categoria quella degli incostanti
persone così curiose che vorrebbero
sapere qualsiasi cosa che amano scoprire
imparare e meravigliarsi così assetate
di novità di stimoli e interessi che
però alla fine rischiano di non
concludere molto e spesso si sentono
perse nella vita
insomma gli incanti sono agli estremi
esperti in niente e multi potenziali in
tutto e Beh ormai l'avrete capito Ciao
Sono Alberto Giannone e sono unico
costante qualcuno di voi si sente come
me
Beh dai non sono non sono l'unico almeno
e oggi quindi voglio raccontarvi come
vivere da in costante in un mondo di
costanti
quando gli organizzatori di questo
evento mi hanno chiesto di scrivere due
righe con la mia biografia io subito
panico chi sono cosa faccio questo
genere di domande mi mettono sempre
ansia perché non riesco a definirmi
fortunatamente ho trovato una soluzione
o meglio un trucchetto Non ditelo in
giro ma la descrizione di ciò che faccio
la cambio in base a chi ho davanti così
per alcune aziende con cui collaboro
Sono un consulente marketing aziendale
Dato che ho studiato economia per alcuni
invece sono un divulgatore scientifico
dato che sui social racconto quanto sia
bella la scienza con il progetto
divulgamente
per altri sono un autore dato che l'anno
scorso ho pubblicato un libro e per mio
nonno Beh a mio nonno dico che faccio
video come quelli che vedi in TV ma su
internet anche se Dalle facce che fa non
mi sembra che abbia capito proprio bene
bene
comunque ci tengo a dire che essere in
costante Non è una scelta ma è il
proprio modo di essere io mi sento in
costante da sempre fin da bambino da
ragazzino ad esempio amavo suonare il
piano sognando di diventare come
Beethoven ma subito dopo prendevo in
mano la chitarra elettrica sognando di
diventare come slash poi alle superiori
ho fatto una scelta abbastanza
controcorrente Infatti dopo due anni ho
cambiato scuola sono passato da un
tecnico e un liceo non perché andassi
male con i voti Anzi andavo benissimo
semplicemente perché avevo capito che
non era la strada giusta per me
e lì c'è scelto era perfetto per
proseguire con università scientifiche
come fisica chimica biologia
mi chiedo ancora Chissà che confusa Sarà
stata la mia prof quando la maturità mi
ha chiesto Giannone ma l'anno prossimo
cosa vuoi studiare e io risposi
psicologia o filosofia e alla fine ho
scelto economia
certo per per un incostante può essere
anche divertente raccontare tutti i
progetti gli aneddoti le esperienze
passate nel tempo ma finiti i momenti di
entusiasmo Ecco che arrivano i momenti
bui perché sia spesso una vocina nella
testa che dice non so cosa fare nella
vita e questa vocina purtroppo mi ha
portato ad abbandonare i diversi
progetti lavorativi solamente perché
proiettandomi nel futuro non sapevo se
fosse quello che volevo fare nella vita
già quando si è in costante ci si sente
eternamente sbagliati in coerenti
insoddisfatti perché si va fuori
dall'immaginario comune e ne sono sicuro
chiunque sia stato incostante o è in
costante almeno una volta nella vita ha
cercato la propria passione o la propria
strada ma spesso non c'è riuscito senza
successo come nel mio caso è ve lo
assicuro io ho provato a fare il
costante in più occasioni ma l'unica
costante è che continuavo a fallire nel
cercare di essere un costante
che così passano gli anni vedo i miei
amici trovare la propria strada trovare
un lavoro sicuro e io sempre con quel
maledetto tormento in testa non so cosa
fare nella vita poi Nel 2020 accade
qualcosa Qualcosa di speciale e No non
sto parlando del coronavirus della
quarantena o altri disastri di
quell'anno sto parlando del natale del
2020 quel giorno Infatti uscì il film
della Pixar Soul
e se non l'avete visto Vi consiglio di
recuperarlo il prima possibile perché
dietro a questo divertente film
d'animazione si nasconde in realtà un
messaggio molto profondo in particolare
una singola frase ha cominciato a
risuonarmi in testa da ora in poi cosa
farai nella vita ne assaporirò ogni
istante Urca mi sono detto ma allora non
è che noi in costante stiamo sbagliando
punto di vista non è che siamo così
focalizzati nella paura di non
raggiungere un obiettivo a lungo termine
che poi ci dimentichiamo di goderci
presente
e grazie a soul quindi la mia testa ha
fatto clic e sono passato da non so cosa
fare nella vita ne assaporerò ogni
istante in quel periodo ad esempio mi
piaceva creare contenuti divulgativi e
quindi vi sono detto Vabbè proviamoci
ora mi impegno mi godo il processo non
mi pongo nessun obiettivo a lungo
termine e vediamo come va Mi sono così
ho cominciato a vivere delle esperienze
bellissime totalmente non programmate
ad esempio ho cominciato a raccontare
quanto sia meravigliosa l'astronomia
passione che avevo Ma che consideravo
inutile per il mio percorso di studio
lavorativo Eppure Grazie proprio a
questo l'agenzia spaziale Europea mi ha
invitato a vedere dal vivo i moduli
della missione Artemis quella che
riporterà gli uomini sulla Luna oltre
che conoscere alcuni Astronauti
raccontare quanto sia bello essere
curiosi mi ha portato a pubblicare un
libro con una grande casa editrice
italiana proprio sulla curiosità e il
non essere focalizzato su un unico
argomento mi ha portato in Etiopia a
passare un periodo in un ospedale nel
reparto di pediatria con una Ong
questi due bambini che vedete erano
gemellini primaturi ma ora sono
cresciuti e stanno bene fortunatamente
tutte queste esperienze
sono state emozionanti ma sono state
completamente inaspettate non me le
sarei mai poste come obiettivo a lungo
termine
e poi chi l'avrebbe detto che tutti i
progetti iniziati quelli conclusi tutte
le passioni arrivate poi scemate mi
avrebbero portato proprio qui oggi a
parlare esattamente di questo
Insomma bisogna ribaltare la visione per
noi in costante non è tanto il
concludere qualcosa che ci rende
appagati ma semplicemente il fare
qualcosa che ci appassioni e attenzione
Non sto dicendo che bisogna usare
l'incostanza come scusa per non
impegnarsi nel proprio lavoro nei propri
studi Anzi semplicemente si può capire
che va benissimo invece di avere un
obiettivo a lungo termine enorme magari
di porsene alcuni di più piccoli a breve
termine
E tutto questo Vi avrà fatto capire che
chi vi vede in costante vive una vita un
po' fuori dagli schemi a volte non sei
neanche compresi da tutti Spesso neanche
da se stessi ma se essere in costante è
la propria indole Allora bisogna sapere
accogliere questo modo di vivere perché
la cosa straordinaria è che con questo
spirito abbracciando l'incostanza
nell'ordinario piccoli o grandi
traguardi possono arrivare in maniera
totalmente inaspettata
e lungo questo viaggio con alcune porte
che si chiudono ma ricco di nuove strade
che si avviano Come dice il protagonista
di Soul Ricordiamoci di assaporarne ogni
istante
[Musica]